Mark: Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Factorio
with Bob!
Hello, Bob.
Bob: What's up, everybody?
Mark: What's up? Ok, so we got a plan
for the next one, and the plan involves testing our intelligence
because...
It's been a while since we've been in college, Bob,
but I imagine that we can still figure this shit out, so...
I... [laughs]
I've reached about the level of where I
have played on my own and now we're in the experimental phase
where we're trying to figure out the best way to automate
literally everything.
Bob: Mm-hmm, Mm-hmm.
Mark: So to do that, we need...
More science, we need more labs,
we need more intricate ways to make those automation machines happen.
So Bob, take it away!
Bob: Well, I did just have an idea.
It's, it's not that smart but I'm about to place a, uh,
Bob: ...smart grabbitty goo behind this chest that's full of...
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: ...coal, but also copper ore...
Bob: ...and recycle the copper ore
into the, uhh
into the line.
Mark: That's smart...
Mark: That is very smart...
Bob:Yeah.
Bob:Oh.
Mark: It doesn't have much to do with the giant automation of
automatic science that I was talking about
but it's smart.
Bob: Yeah, I know I- It's cool, though, right? So...
Mark: Yeah, err...
Bob: I just need some wood to-
Mark: It's pretty cool...
Bob: to, to, make a, to make
Bob: a lot- a power pole 'cus my power systems sucks.
Mark: Hehe, yeah.
I mean, I wasn't going to question, but you got like a criss-crossing web of horror...
And, uhh...
Mine is all nice and unique. But!
That's fine, that's beautiful. I love it.
Bob: Alright, it's not, it's not grabbing out of the chest.
Mark: Uh...
Mark: It should be--
Bob: It's supposed to-
Bob: It's supposed to grab out of the chest...
Mark: Oh, there's no copper in there.
Mark: So, it's-
Bob: Oh, oh, I just took it out.
Mark: Yeah, I'm just gonna-
Bob: Hang on.
Mark: I put, yes, see, there, there we go!
Bob: Oh!
Mark: It's beautiful...
Bob: Oh, I'm a genius...
Mark: An automation 2 finish!
Which means that we can make the bigger assembly machines.
And the bigger assembly chine-machines
means... that we can make, uh,
automatically make products that take 3 items.
Mark: So, now, we can automate "Science 2",
Bob: Alright.
Mark: because it needs to make the inserters.
Bob: Alright, well, we should do that.
Mark: Yes, we should do that.
Bob: That sounds fun.
Mark: Okay.
So, this requires an even bigger loop with even more automation facilities
and a whole bunch of crap, so....
Bob: I can only imagine.
Mark: Yes, so we-
Bob: How- I could- [laughs]
Bob: Where, where uh... where are we gonna build this?
To the right over there in that clearing?
Mark: Yeah, that would actually-
Bob: To the right of our original science factory?
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: That would actually make a lot of sense.
Because if we do it over here, then we can just keep clearing out the woods here and then...
[Wood chopping noises]
Keep it a little bit away from the lake.
That way, we can keep the steam engines going at the lake.
But soon! We'll be able to make solar power. Which would be very nice.
Bob: Hmm! Solar power sounds awesome.
Mark: Yeah, but the th-the thing about solar power is, it's only available during the day
and you still have to rely on steam engines until you get more stuff.
I mean, eventually... [Wood chopping noises]
I haven't gotten there yet, but you'll get oil processing and you'll be able to do that stuff and...
and just generally be able to-
[Wood chopping noises]
Bob: That sounds really complicated. So I'm just gonna build two of these new assembling machines.
Mark: Okay!
Bob: 'Cus, 'cus I can and I assume we need them-
Mark: Probably -
Bob: And it takes-
Bob: It takes some amount of time.
[Wood chopping noises]
Mark: Yep.
Bob: Either like a day, or like, five minutes, or...
Mark: Yep, something like that.
Mark: I mean, I've got- Ok, I've got...
Let's see. I've got...
Why do I only have one?
Mark: I should have...
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: 5 assembly machines?
Oh, they're on their way, they're still being made.
Ok, so...
Alright, thinking about this, using my big brain.
Mark: So to make science, th- the green science, th- the science pack 2 you'll need
an inserter and a transport belt.
So you'll need an assembly machine that's making the transport belts which makes
transport belts just take iron plates and gear wheels,
so you need a machine making gear wheels
in the same loop that's making the
transporter belts you need...
Inserters...
Because...
And Inserters are the ones that take 3 ingredients so you need another machine that's making
electronic circuits.
And to make an electronic circuit, you'll need another machine that's making
copper cable out of copper plate.
So.
Mark: The only-
Bob: Fuck!
Mark: Yeah, I know.
Mark: The only inputs are iron and copper,
but the assembly machines inside are also making
copper cable,
iron gears
and...
Was there anything else?
Electronic circuits.
So, copper cable.
Mark: Iron gears.
Bob: Here, I, I got the start for you, ready?
Mark: Ok, I'm ready.
Bob: Nailed it.
Mark: [Giggling] Thank you Bob.
Mark: Thank you. [Laughs]
Bob: Nailed it. I just want to say...
Bob: I contributed.
Bob: You are...
Bob: You are welcome, sir.
Mark: Thank you Bob, you are...
Bob: Let's just marvel at our brilliance for a second here
Mark: You know what?
I, I can't deny this is- might- this might be the most important thing that you've ever built here.
Mark: Which is incredible.
Bob: I, uh,
Bob: you might say...
I came up with the entire idea.
Mark: Yeah! I would say you did that.
And also I realized we can't build here because the freaking stone is in the way!
Bob: Awesome.
Mark: Like, what a dick!
Bob: So, well...
Yeah, okay, so, I'll- just- I'll-
Mark: We could do it to- the s-
We could do it to the south here.
Bob: Okay
Mark: Yeah, I didn't mean to totally destroy your incredible planned place...
Bob: I'll just-
Mark: ...putting up the chests [Laughs]
Bob: Oh, it's okay, I'll just, it's okay, I'll- it's okay
Mark: Are you sure you're okay? Because I don't, I don't wanna, I don't wanna make you mad, you know.
Mark: Oh!
Bob: So, how the shit do I destroy this damn rock?
[Gunshots] Oh, you can destroy it with your gun, it just takes a lot of...
Mark: [Mimicking the sound of the gunshots] Dum dum dum dum-
Bob: Dammit.
Mark: [Still mimicking the sound of the gunshots] Dum dum (x5)
It's working!
Bob: I'm almost out of ammo, though...
Mark: Don't worry, we've got, we've got an automation facility that- there we go!
It just, it, this, it vanished.
Mark: Uhm...
Bob: I now got lots of ammo.
Mark: Well, too late now, it's already gone.
Bob: Got lots of ammo. Leave me alone.
Mark: Okay, I'd- I've- I was- I command you on your ammo.
I'm actually shocked that we haven't been attacked yet
because they, at home, haven't seen the aliens yet!
Bob: I know! [Laughs]
The unbelievable pain and suffering that was brought upon us in the la- in the
pre-recording stuff.
Mark: Yeah, the extreme "douchetry" of us dying horribly to horrifying aliens.
Mark: Okay. So, in the loop you on- we only need one gear maker.
Bob: Oh, okay
Mark: Because it, it makes gears super fast
so we only need one. So let's just place 'em down, one at a time.
I'll place one, then you place one, and then we'll just go from there.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: I'll go steal all the iron.
Mark: Okay, so.
One th- of these. That's for gears. So I'm gonna make this for gears.
Bob: Okay.
Mark: Alright, so it only needs iron.
So the next one... Uhm, because we need to make an inserter and we need to make
transport belts, we need- Ok, so the thing
that makes transport belts only needs
gears and metal, so those are both gonna
be coming in.
Makes sense?
Bob: Yes. No.
Mark: No? God dammit, Bob.
Bob: Alright, so I'm just trying to visualize in my mind.
So we need one arm taking up
Bob: ...iron and putting it into this one.
Mark: Yes.
Bob: Okay. I can visualize that. Should it be faster or- no,
Bob: ...it should just be regular...
Mark: Yeah, regular electronic inserter.
Bob: Okay. So I'll put an inserter like this, like just for now
and assume the belt, maybe it'll run over here, we'll see what happens.
Mark: Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. That's good assumption. And this one's gonna be the transport
machine.
So this, th- It'll grab...
It'll grab from here...
Or it'll grab on the belt after this one's done and then it'll go here.
And then...
Bob: So this one needs an arm, like, say, up here? Going into it?
Mark: Yes. That is one-
Bob: 'kay.
Mark: Okay. So that's going there, and then the next one is the starting of
making... The inserter parts, so we need one machine here making copper cables.
So we need another, right there, making copper cable.
Mark: Alright. I hope you're writing this down, because there will be a quiz!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: I'm talking to the people out there.
Mark: So, that one's making copper cable.
Bob: So. Okay?
Mark: And then the next one is gonna take the copper cable and mix it with iron plate to make electronic.
So this one's for electronics.
And then finally, at the end of the loop is one that is making the inserter itself
which takes four parts, so I think we can... Bring it back around... So we're saying we're looping down.
And then that goes there.
So this is making the inserters...
So then we have transport belt coming out of this one,
all the ingredients for the inserter coming out of this one,
and then we can just put the machines that are gonna make the science,
and we can overdo that, so how
many, uh, level one assembly machines do you have?
Bob: Four.
Mark: Okay. Put three right behind those other ones.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: Just wanna make level one science.
Mark: No, level TWO science. This is a level TWO science.
Bob: Just wanna make level two science.
Mark: [Laughs] You were- Oh, you were so close to being right, there, Bob, you were doing great.
But. Okay.
Ugh! Alright, so... now we've got three of these for level three science.
So I'm gonna make just a loop around it... Whoops!
Mark: Aw, fuck, oh God, I'm so drunk when I make these.
Bob: Yeah. They, they still- They still need the inserters in, right?
Mark: Yes. So
work on making the inserters...
And I will ma- Why is the music so ominous?
Bob: Heh.
Mark: Di- did you hear that?
Bob: No reason. Nothing horrible is about to happen at all.
Mark: [Laughs] Nothing, why would you question anything?
Bob: Don't worry about it.
Mark: I, I wasn't worried. Okay.
Bob: I'm, I'm gonna be really impressed if this all pans out. I just wanna say that.
Mark: Yeah. Because also I'm gonna try to make a splitter.
We're in the, in a part of this, and I don't even know how splitters work.
But I built one, so let's give it a go.
Bob: [Snickers]
Mark: And I've also got underground belts.
Okay, splitter.
Bob: Oh, you're making a splitter? I was just gonna make a smart grabber.
Mark:Smart grabber too, but also splitter-
What is- THAT is a splitter? What is that doing?
Bob: What the hell?
Mark: What does it do?
Can I make a smart splitter?
Oh, God! What would that do to it?
Mark: I don't know what that do!
Bob: Ah, geez!
Mark: Ugh.
Bob: So what happens if you put one into it?
Mark: Uh...
I don't know. Just for... sanity sake, I'm gonna...
Oh, I guess-! Wait, hang on, we could have made these- okay.
Actually, I'm going to... redo these just
to save some space, so going...
Bob: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Mark: ...going out. We could have made them all like... this.
Yeah! Yeah!
In... In... and... out.
Mark: Crap! Okay.
Bob: [Snickers]
Mark: There we go.
Mark: God damn... There we go.
Okay. So now we can just bring the loop farther in, and that should be okay.
Bob: Oh, okay.
Mark: And then I have no goddamn idea how the splitter's gonna work, so
we're gonna look at that after we get this thing actually going.
Okay! So now go get some iron and copper and then we're gonna just be building the...
Outside parts into it.
Bob: Oh, I've got lots of iron and copper, don't you worry about it
Mark: Oh, I would, I would- I should nev- I should learn never be worried when you're around.
Bob: I got, I got all that. I got all that in here.
Mark: Yeah. Okay. So, IN THEORY, this should work.
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: I don't know- I don't know why I feel the need to yell that
but I'm just like, in theory, this should absolutely, hundred percent, without a doubt, work.
Bob: Oh, you're doing that already. I just made a bunch of power poles.
Mark: Ah, it's cool.
Bob: I'm too slow.
Mark: Nah, I got you covered.
Alright, we're a team! Cooperative, remember?
Bob: Alright, that's gotta be everything powered up right?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: So now we just need inputs... Hang on, I've got the inputs, don't worry about it.
Mark: I wasn't worried. Why would I be worried?
Bob: So the input should start right here because this will put them right into the beginning of the process, right?
Mark: Hmm, yes...
Bob: Like that.
Mark: Yes. Yeah. Absolutely.
Bob: Aw, shit.
Bob: Except for I putting it outside the stupid thing.
Mark: It's okay, I won't criticize.
Bob: Just, yeah, thank you for not saying anything out loud, I appreciate that.
Mark: You're doing wonderful.
Bob: And then I need a bunch of copper...
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: And...
Mark: Yeah. [Mining sounds]
Okay.
Now, they're facing... the wrong way, I'll spin them around for ya.
Bob: Ah, yeah. Indeed, indeed.
Mark: [Laughs] So now it should be- grab, yes, okay.
Gear machine is going. Copper wire machine is going, copper wire just went in...
Yeah? Okay. I like it. Ok. Alright, cool.
Mark: I need to put lights around here so we can see them
Bob: Yeah, I was just gonna grab some more resources. Oh, you've got resources for lights.
Mark: Boink! [Laughs] I've got it all covered.
Bob: Nah, whatever. I was thinking that same thing, I was right there. I was thinking it with you.
Mark: [Laughs] It's okay, we understand. And now...
Bob: The blue- The blue one is doing things.
Mark: Yeah. Oh, I just finished steel processing. Yeah. Okay.
So the blue one's turning out inserters, or it's thinking about it, really hard.
Bob: It's- It needs iron plates, still, to come around.
Mark: Ah, okay. It's, it's just gonna-
Bob: Iron plate has not made it around yet.
Mark: The, the-
Bob: Oh, shit.
Mark: Damn, the-
Mark: ...the the gear is really greedy on the iron plate.
Bob: Yeah...
Mark: The gearbox is literally chugging all the iron.
Okay. Yeah.
Bob: I should make a different iron supply for that side.
Bob: Spread out a little bit.
Mark: Uh, yeah, that might be a good idea.
I'm thinking we probably need more electronics production?
Because this is a lot of copper wire.
So, one gear is more than enough for everything, but what we might need is more electronics production.
So I might extend this, but let's see how this goes first.
No, not there! It's just gonna- it's gonna
feedback to the gears!
Bob: No, it's not. It's gonna go right in here.
Mark: Oh, ok, nevermind then. Oh, wait- No, the electronics needs iron too!
Bob: Oh, balls.
Mark: I guess we could have just put the one by the electronics and then...
Mark: Let it-
Bob: So, which one is the electronics? This one?
Mark: Yeah, this top right. Top right is electronics.
Bob: So I should put it like, here.
Mark: Yeah. That would be okay.
Bob: Any, any day now I'll understand completely what in the hell I'm supposed to be-
Mark: [Laughs]
Bob: Oh, I didn't put the iron in.
Mark: I don't think any of us are expected to know exactly what the hell we're doing because
we could read guides and shit.
Mark: But why do that?
Bob: Nah. No.
Mark: Oh God.
Bob: Does that sound like something that we would do?
Mark: It sounds like something we would attempt to do and then blame each other for failing.
Okay, I'm gonna see what the splitter does.
It did nothing.
Bob: I think you have to put it in the path of something.
Mark: What? What are you talking about?
Bob: Like here, here, watch.
Bob: What if we, like...
Bob: Oh, this is gonna fuck everything up if I do this.
Mark: I'm down for it.
Bob: I think we should make an experimental...
Bob: Well, whatever. I was gonna go like this...
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: And turn this so that it...
It wa- Hey!
There.
Now put the splitter like on the end of that and see what happens.
Mark: Oh!
Ah!
Bob: Hm.
Mark: That's weird!
Bob: Now everything is ruined here and it's gonna-
Mark: I would think it's a horrorful-
[Both laugh]
Mark: God dammit!
I just wanna see it produce one science, though. I know this can produce one science. It can do it!
Bob: I feel like this is not possibly the most efficient way that this is set up, could be set up.
'Cus it seems like...
I just don't know how to space it out any differently.
Mark: It's okay, it's cool.
Bob: This episode is a lot of us just making thinking faces.
Mark: Yeah. It's- It's okay, because we just got the electronics-
Bob: Hey, I'm seeing some electronics coming out.
Mark: Yeah, one of the electronics was facing the wrong direction, so.
It's okay. It's fine. C'mon!
Oh, okay. The assembly...
Is...There's not a lot of room in the outside of that band.
But it's going forward. It's thinking about it.
Oh, it's making sc- It made a science! It's just, no room on the belt!
Bob: It just needs to put it down somewhere.
Mark: [Laughs] Yay!
Bob: [Laughs]
Mark: We made ONE!
Bob: We fucking did it, man.
Mark: Oh, man. Well, now it's actually consuming a lot more products now that science is going.
Bob: And now it's really cranking.
Mark: Okay. I think it just needs some balancing. Like,
it needs to have more of some, less of others, and then, bigger loop in general but I think this is actually a good design.
Mark: Well, not-
Bob: There's another science coming out.
Mark: Yay!
Bob: I'm gonna ride that science to the end.
Mark: Yay! Well, it's not a good design, but it's, it...
Bob: No...
Mark: ...it, it, it, it does things.
Mark: It eventually....
Bob: Hey, you know what? It makes. Science.
Mark: Yay!
Bob: We've now got a chest with four level two science things.
Mark: YAY!
Okay. So that's good enough for this episode! Thank you everybody so much for watching.
[Outro music starts faintly playing]
Thank you Bob for helping me figure to help that out, because holy hell, that was, that took
Bob: That was amazing.
Mark: brain power!
[Both laugh]
Mark: I'm sure everyone in the comments is marveling at our intelligence but-
Thank you Bob, and thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always, we will see you in the next video.
Buh-bye!
[Outro music playing]
Whale, whale, whale. More sea lambs to the slaughter.
Bear hug. Bear Grillz! How many bear puns are we gonna fit it here? Can I get a bear counter?